[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
comme tous les lundis trèard bonjour Y
merci d'être avec nous directeur adjoint
de la rédaction du Figaro et on est ravi
de retrouver Mathilde Sirot bonjour
Mathilde merci d'être là journaliste
politique au point on va parler avec
vous de la situation en Israël après les
attaques terroristes du Hamas gerérald
dermana a renforcé la sécurisation des
lieux de culte juif faut-il craindre une
importation du conflit en France y
a-t-il des inquiétudes au sein du
gouvernement on en parlera et si la
classe politique a dans son ensemble
condamné ces attaque la réaction de la
France insoumise fait parler on verra ça
évidemment avec vous Alex on va
également parler de la loi immigration
il y a de la friture sur les lignes au
sein du gouvernement oui le débat sur la
loi immigration c'est dans moins d'un
mois au Sénat et les intentions du du
gouvernement ne sont pas encore très
clairs on en parle d'abord on voit
l'actualité dans nos
[Musique]
régions l'actualité dans nos régions
avec nos partenaires de la presse
régionale et c'est également le grand
retour de guilem ricavi bonjour guilem
merci d'être avec nous bonjour directeur
éditorial à Var Matin on est ravi de
vous retrouver dans ces beaux paysages
méditerranéens ben également on va on va
évidemment parler Israël avec vous dans
quelques instants mais d'abord on va
regarder on va parler de votre une et à
lire évidemment dans vos pages un
dossier complet sur les interventions
des secours en mer de plus en plus
nombreuse guilem
oui effectivement orien de plus en plus
nombreuse he écoutez sur les 12 derniers
mois il y a eu un petit peu plus de 1000
interventions de des différentes forces
de secours le long de la côte varoise
alors c'est un nombre qui est très
important et c'est surtout un nombre qui
est en hausse par rapport aux années
précédentes rien que sur la période
estivale on enregistre une hausse de 15
15 % des interventions et donc au
préalable des accidents et d'ailleurs
cela suscite l'inquiétude du préfet
maritime qui appelle de ses vœux la
réforme du permis bateau parce que selon
lui il n'est plus adapté aujourd'hui il
est la cause de nombreux dangers parce
que tout le monde aujourd'hui peut louer
très facilement un bateau mais tout le
monde ne connaît pas les règles de
sécurité et donc ce préfet maritime en
appel à l'état pour réformer ce permis
bateau pour le rendre un petit peu plus
compliqué plus en phase avec les
pratiques actuel puisqu'on le sait bien
aujourd'hui sur la mer aujourd'hui les
les pratiques maritimes et de nautisme
se diversifient et se multiplie et c'est
à lire évidemment dans V ce matin à lire
également comme dans beaucoup de titres
de la presse régionale ce matin
guillemme l'attaque contre Israël et la
douleur et l'inquiétude des Juifs de
France c'est l'autre titre à votre une
oui effectivement et particulièrement
ici dans le sud de la France dans cette
région où la communauté juive et nombre
à Marseille mais pas seulement à Toulon
et à Nice également et vous vous en
doutez les Juifs de France sont
particulièrement inquiets de ces 48
heures de combat auquel ils ont pu
assister ils sont inquiets pour leur
pays ils sont inquiets aussi pour leurs
proches qui sont làbas et qui aimerait
pour certains revenir les vols sont
parfois pris d'assaut il y a donc une
inquiétude majeure ici et on vit heure
par heure ce conflit ici depuis la
région sud Provence albecôte d'Azur un
petit peu comme si on était
sur place en Israël ou en Palestine
merci guilem merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous évidemment tout ça c'est à
lire dans Var Matin on revoit la une la
mer de tous les dangers et la douleur et
l'inquiétude des Juifs de France merci
guilem à très vite j'espère merci
d'avoir été avec nous on va revenir avec
vous évidemment sur cette situation en
Israël d'abord Yve c'était c'est une
attaque surprise est-ce qu'on peut
parler de guerre ellisabeth bornier elle
a elle a refusé d'employer ce terme
parlait d'attaque terroriste c'est une
attaque terroriste c'est pas on compare
souvent avec
1973 et la guerre de Kipour mais la
guerre de Kipour c'était deux arm
c'était l'armée israélienne face à des
armées arabes d'État arabes là c'est pas
du tout le cas là vous avez un groupe
terroriste qui est fiché comme tel qui
s'appelle le ramass qui fait la puuie et
le BE temp sur la bande de Gaza qui est
en rivalité avec le fata qui lui est
plutôt en 6 Jordanie et qui fait une
attaque terror ça ressemble beaucoup
plus d'une certaine façon au 11
septembre 2001 vous avez eu une attaque
terroriste sur les États-Unis bah là
c'est pareil en plus avec une et et
pourquoi c'est pareil parce que c'est
une attaque contre des civils beaucoup
de civils qui ont été tués pris en otage
blessé parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
blessés et donc on est plus dans un une
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui une guerre
asymétrique que dans une guerre
classique entre deux armées en bonne et
du forme est-ce que c'est ça suscite
l'inquiétude au sein du gouvernement
Mathilde ce qui est en train de se
passer en Israël euh bien sûr il y a eu
des réactions d'ailleurs au niveau
international diplomatique et des
condamnations quasiment unanimes ensuite
il y a eu très vite un débat politique
en France qui s'est qui s'est noué
autour en fait de la prise de position
ou l'absence de prise de position de la
France insoumise il y a eu desès samedis
des des des des ce weekend en fait des
réactions euh dans tout le le le camp
politique pour condamner l'attaque
terroriste sauf du côté des insoumis où
l'on a tendance à renvoyer d'ux atau le
mouvement palestinien et l'État
israélien donc il y a eu des des des
déclarations très fortes hein de la
première ministre ellisabeth borne qui
qui en fait a dit que souscouvert
d'antisionisme finalement les les les
insoumis se se compromettaient dans
l'antisémitisme et on voit bien des des
des des fractures encore une fois qui
sont pas nouvelles hein mais qui qui qui
rejaillissent au sein de de l'Alliance
de gauche donc un débat politique qui se
noue et évidemment un activisme
diplomatique au sommet de l'état de la
part d'Emmanuel Macron et duquor très
important notamment concernant aussi les
les ressortissants français qui sont sur
place ouais qui sont sur place et il y a
aussi euh une inquiétude parce que
Gérald harmanin a très vite annoncé la
sécurisation des lieux de la communauté
juive il y a aussi une inquiétude pour
les Juifs qui sont ici c'est en France
oui alors ça c'est une inquiétude
régulière vous disiez en préambule tout
à l'heure que euh est-ce que ce conflit
pourrait être importé je dirais que on
vit en permanence avec l'importation de
ce conflit parce que ce qui se passe
beaucoup entre une partie he une petite
partie de la
communauté musulmane et les tensions qui
peut y avoir dans certains quartiers
très souvent ont pour prétexte ce qui se
passe au Proche Orient et ça on le le
viit depuis bah grosso modo depuis 67 la
guerre des 6 jours depuis après il y a
eu la guerre de Kip pour et et puis
l'attitude de des des gouvernement
français donc il y a toujours eu si vous
voulez en toile de fond de la tension
qui existe dans certains quartiers en
France où il y a une forte communauté
musulmane ce conflit euh et regardez ce
que ça peut donner comme dans des
localités comme sarcell par exemple où
vous aviez dans jadis parce que c'est
plus tellement le cas juste une forte
communauté juive c'est fararad venant
d'Afrique du Nord qui après 62 s'est
installé dans ses quartiers enfin dans
cette région dans cette périphérie de
Paris qui a quitté peu à peu de plus en
plus qui quitte sarcelle parce que
justement il y a des tensions très vives
avec la communauté musulmane sur place
donc on vit avec ça évidemment en plus
il faut le savoir le ramas c'est c'est
pas seulement un un groupe peu
nationaliste hein on est loin de la
périodeasser Arafat l'OLP où c'était un
combat nationaliste aujourd'hui c'est ce
combat nationaliste se double d'une
expression religieuse et d'une
expression
fondamentaliste islamique donc il est là
le sujet aussi alors mathil vous disiez
un trèsvite il y a eu des réactions de
la classe politique assez unanime sauf
la France insoumise une position de la
France insoumise qui a fait vivement
réagir Elisabeth la première ministre on
l'écoute on peut pas dans le contexte
actuel renvoyer dos à dos et le Hamas
dont je rappelle que c'est une
organisation reconnue comme une
organisation terroriste par l'Union
européenne on a d'un côté un état qui
est VI un État démocratique qui est
victime d'une attaque terroriste et de
l'autre cet état qui se défend donc ces
propos sont totalement choquant et
totalement déplacés les positions de la
France insoumise sont bien connues avec
avec beaucoup d'ambiguité avec de
l'antiionisme donc en effet c'est
parfois une façon aussi de masquer une
forme d'antisémitisme il est choquant
d'avoir un responsable politique qui
réagit quand je suis en train de
condamner l'attaque d'un groupe
terroriste sur un État démocratique avec
les images qu'on a tous vu C hier midi
chez nos confrère de BFM une réaction
très ferme de la part d'Élisabeth Bor
Mathilde oui effectivement des des mots
des mots très fermes très clairs euh
finalement cette ces positions de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de quelques-uns de
ces plus fidèles lieutenants n'a étonné
personne euh c'est pas c'est c'est
malheureusement pas la première fois et
il y a eu par le passé de la part de la
France insoumise la participation par
exemple à des manifestations du
collectif contre l'islamophobie qui
depuis a été dissou et euh beaucoup de
de de prise de position très ambigu euh
et et et notamment aussi sur sur ces
questions de
d'antisémitisme et C ai aussi documenté
que c'est une stratégie purement
électorale que de
vouloir voilà flatter ou en tout cas
s'attirer des voix de de de communauté
qui se retrouvent dans un discours
parfois il faut le dire complottiste
vis-à-vis des juif et cette réaction de
Jean-Luc malencho elle est très
critiquée notamment à gauche et même au
sein même de la France insoumise avec
par exemple François Ruffin qui lui a
fait une condamnation très claire de
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas François
Ruffin qui peut-être aussi pour des
visés en vue de la présidentielle 2027
c'est très bien qu'il doit se distancier
de ses positions polémiques de la France
insoumise et d'ailleurs le tweet de
François Ruffin a été soutenu par un
autre insoumis Alexis Corbier donc il a
aussi de la friture sur la ligne au sein
même de LFI ouais division au sein de
LFI mais la position de de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon elle est pas surprenante comme
disait Mathilde non parce qu'il a fait
un choix Jean-Luc Mélenchon et il a fait
le choix vous savez c'est un peu la
droite des allocations des allocations
et la droite et la droite la gauche
desallocations et la gauche du du
travail c'est cette cette division qu'on
trouve entre d'un côté Ruffin Rousell
euh au sein de la gauche et puis de
l'autre côté
euh la la gauche des minorités la gauche
discriminée que défend la gauche des
banlieux que défend et de certaines
zones périphériqu que défend Mélenchon
bah voilà c'est c'est c'est tout le
débat de la gauche hein et moi je pense
que c'est très cyque ce que je ve dire
mais Mélenchon il sait pertinemment ce
qu'il fait c'est de l'opportunisme
électoral et probablement que son
opportunisme électoral sera davantage
couronné que le discours de de de Ruffin
ou de c'est comme
ça c'est lui qui aès jusqu'à présent a
fait les SC hein c'est pas les autres
notamment dans les quartiers populaires
et notamment en scène Saint-Denis
effectivement c'est lui qui a fait les
scores si vous regardez les dernières la
dernière présidentielle et les dernières
législatives c'est lui qui emporte la
mise dans toutes les banlieux des
grandes cités de Paris à Marseille en
passant par Lyon enfin voilà Lille c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est ce discours là
qui est entendu
euh au prix de sans doute de prise de
position bah qui sont plus que
critiables qui sont les positions de de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon une forme
d'antisémitisme comme le dit ellisabeth
borne alors l'antisciionisme se nourrit
souvent
d'antisémitisme évidemment ça c'est très
clair dire que c'est ce qu'il faut c'est
ce qui qualifie Jean-Luc Mélenchon je ne
sais pas mais c'est sûr que
l'antisionisme c'est de l'antisémitisme
et du clientélisme électoral Mathilde de
la part de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon du clientélisme en tout cas
une stratégie électorale clair qui est
de prendre parti euh et c'est ce qu'on a
pu voir aussi dans d'autres gauches on
pense à à Corbin en Grande-Bretagne qui
notamment avait été aussi pris en défaut
au sein de son de son parti le Parti
travailliste pour des des des prises de
position des ambiguïés vis-à-vis d'un
d'un discours alors l'antisémitisme est
un délit donc c'est toujours voilà c'est
c'est c'est évidemment condamnable mais
des ambiguïés et et évidemment comme le
disait Yve de de jouer avec
l'antisionisme euh qui parfois est le le
cashsex aussi de l'antisémitisme
Jean-Luc Mélenchon cet été on s'en
souvient ils on étit pris violemment
aussi au CRIF les accusant d'extrême
droite enfin c'est toute une une
stratégie donc électorale on l'a dit
mais aussi idéologique assumé de la part
du leader des insoumis on va passer à
l'autre thème de ce club on va parler de
la loi immigration elle arrive dans un
mois au Sénat et Alexe à moins d'un mois
de son examen quelques zones de flou
persiste toujours autour de ce texte oui
Orian alors on le rappelle le
gouvernement a besoin des voix des
républicains pour faire passer ce projet
de loi immigration un texte qui prévoit
d'un côté de faciliter les les
expulsions d'étrangers délinquants ou
criminels mais de l'autre ce texte
prévoit également de régulariser les
travailleurs sans papier dans les
secteurs en tension c'est l'article 3 du
projet de loi et c'est cette mesure dont
ne veulent absolument pas les
parlementaires les les républicains car
ils estiment que cela va créer un appel
d'air migratoire le problème c'est que
gauche de la majorité présidentielle
est-elle très attachée à cette mesure de
régularisation alors au final que va
faire le gouvernement va-t-il garder ce
dispositif dans le projet de loi de l'IM
immigration la réponse est plutôt oui
mais dimanche et bien la première
ministre ellisabeth borne interrogé sur
BFM sur ce sujet et bien a eu beaucoup
de mal à répondre et les journalistes
l'ont interrogé ont répété les questions
plusieurs fois est-ce que cet article
figurera bien quoi qu'il en coûte dans
le projet de loi immigration et vous
n'avez pas répondu isabth band est-ce
que ce sera dans le texte ou pas les les
Français je pense que certaines
situations ne sont pas ne peuvent pas
être traité dans le cadre actuel de la
loi notamment si une entreprise
peut-être dans un certain nombre de cas
volontairement emploie des personnes en
situation irrégulière et n'en demande
pas la régularisation donc ce que vous
nous dites c'est que vous êtes vous
passerez par la loi vous êtes obligé de
toute façon cette modification
législative est nécessaire voilà ça a
été dur maisisabeth bne a fini par il y
a un autre sujet sur lequel le
gouvernement n'a pas tranché c'est
l'aide médicale d'État oui l'aide
médicale d'État couvre les soins
médicaux des étrangers en situation
irrégulière sur notre sol depuis moins
de 3 mois et qui ne bénéficie pas de la
protection universelle maladie l'ame
représente actuellement un budget d'1,2
milliard d'euros par an et jusque-là une
réforme de l'aide médicale d'État
n'était pas prévue dans ce projet de loi
immigration mais hier dans le journal Le
Parisien et bien le ministre de
l'Intérieur géralde Darmanin a changé un
petit peu la donne en faisant cette
déclaration
regardez je le cite à titre personnel je
suis favorable à la proposition faite
par les républicains et les centristes
de supprimer l'aide médicale d'État et
de la transformer en aide médicale
d'urgence et derrière cet avis personnel
de Géraldo daranin se cache en fait une
réflexion lancée par le gouvernement
écoutez Elisabeth borne nous allons
confier une mission à deux
personnalités Patrick stéepanini bien
connu des républicains et claud Dvin
ancien ministre de la Santé pour nous
aider à faire le point sur ce dispositif
et à voir si le cas échéant des
adaptations sont nécessaires la position
du gouvernement elle résultera bien sûr
des conclusions de cette mission et à
voir si une future réforme de l'aide
médicale d'État se transformera en gage
donné par le gouvernement aux
républicains pour voter ce texte
immigration car on le rappelle la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
vote chaque année dans le budget de la
Sécurité sociale cette restriction de la
me ouis Mathilde est-ce qu' à force de
vouloir trouver un accord ou de devoir
trouver un accord avec les républicains
le gouvernement se retrouve dans un
grand flou sur ce texte mais le
gouvernement se retrouve surtout dans
une impasse sur ce projet de loi
immigration imaginez quand même que
c'est c'était il y a un an que Olivier
dusopt et Gérald arm nous présentaient
ce texte c'était en novembre 2022 donc
voilà bientôt un an qu'on est sur ce
texte on voit bien que là le
gouvernement se se heurte en même temps
parce qu'en en essayant de vouloir
ménager la chèvre et le chou et d'avoir
à la fois cette volonté de régulariser
des travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension et d'être plus ferme
sur les les obligations de quitter le
territoire français par exemple et bien
ce n'est plus possible en en temps de
majorité relative il y avait eu cette
tentation à un moment donné de de
scinder le texte en deux pour pouvoir le
voter peut-être d'une d'une certaine
manière d'un côté avec la gauche de
l'autre avec la droite comme comme ce
qui avait été fait sur les questions
d'écologie et d'énergie renouvelable et
de nucléaire l'année l'année passée
finalement on revient à un texte global
euh avec vraiment une impasse
stratégique parce que d'un côté gerérald
haranin est tenté de vouloir mettre le
RN et LR face à ses contradiction en
allant euh plutôt de leur côté en
donnant des gages euh à la droite mais
de l'autre on voit aussi une aile gauche
de la majorité qui ne veut pas euh faire
entendre raison à Gérald amadin et qui
et qui veut garder à tout prix euh ce
volet régularisation avec certainement
euh l'appui euh non assumé comme tel
mais de d'Élisabeth borne bien sûr qui
est premier ministre qui veut que
là-dessus le texte soit équilibré elle
le répète et qui vient elle aussi de la
gauche donc là on on on arrive vraiment
c'est la quintessence de de de l'échec
du en même temps appliqué à la majorité
relative et on a peine à voir comment le
gouvernement pourrait s'en dépriter
d'autant plus que LR là-dessus si jamais
le gouvernement devait devait sortir le
le 493 pour faire adopter ce texte a dit
clairement on ira à la motion de censure
donc c'est c'est vraiment l'impasse
politique pour l'exécutif ouais c'est
l'impossible acccord une véritable
impassive oui mais on se demande s'ils
ont pas fait exprès d'une certaine façon
c'estàd que on en parle ça fait quand
même un moment qu'on parle de ça euh non
ma rappel ça ça permet de de cliver de
euh de de de dire bah oui oui non mais
c'est un sujet important parce que quand
même l'immigration ça figure parmi les
les sujets les préoccupations les plus
les premières des des des Français mais
finalement bon bah parce que comme on
veut êt gentil un peu avec la gauche euh
bon le sujet est à l'ordre du jour mais
finalement il se pourrait qu' se passe
rien euh voà Géral d'manin il dit faut
arrêter de retarder son adoptionou mais
ça fait quand même un an qu'il le dit
euh d'ailleurs il était prêt à passer en
disant par le 493 dès le début il a dit
mais pourquoi on nutilise pas le 493
avec ça Gérald Darman d'ailleurs il
était pas du tout question au début
qu'on régularise les clandestins dans
les métiers entention c'était pas dans
le c'était pas le sujet puis tout à coup
on on a vu débarquer dans une interview
au Monde je crois que c'était Olivier du
sopt qui nous a présenté ça enfin bon
c'est une espèce de salade nissoise euh
avec des ingrédients qui sont pas
toujours c'est c'est à mon avis très peu
clair pour le grand public mais le mot
immigration surgit donc voilà euh c'est
ça qui est important alors est-ce que ça
va déboucher sur quelque chose ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ça commence
par le Sénat vous l'aurez remarqué euh
donc c'est un gage aussi de sagesse de
ération pour un un un sujet qui est
plutôt assez brûlant est-ce que au bout
du compte on arrivera à voter et adopter
est-ce qu'ils arriveront à à adopter une
loi qui soit efficace sur pareil si elle
est je
dirais
tricôter enfin un pas en avant un pas en
arrière il se passera rien VO et puis on
rappelle que ce texte arrive dans un
contexte de campagne des élections
européennes qui va vraiment démarré et
qui va mettre l'immigration voilà le
sujet migratoire est de plus en plus
important dans l'actualité européenne on
l'a vu ces dernières semaines avec ce
qui se passe à Lampedusa donc finalement
d'une certaine manière Emmanuel Macron
est piégé il doit faire quelque chose il
doit faire passer une loi sur
l'immigration pour montrer qu'il est
volontariste sur cette question sinon il
va subir les foudres de la droite et du
rassemblement national notamment dans
cette campagne européenne et puis il y a
aussi une forme de pression de jles
daranin qui a du poids politique dans ce
gouvernement et qui lui veut faire
passer cette loi immigration parce que
ça fait partie également de ses
convictions politiques et elle est
partagé cette volonté de faire aboutir
la loi ou c'est uniquement Gérald
hermanin qui qui pousse pour la faire
aboutir le sujet de l'immigration pour
la majorité d'Emmanuel Macron c'est un
sujet c'est le sujet le plus compliqué à
côté la réforme des retraites ça paraît
beaucoup plus facile parce qu'ils
étaient tous d'accord plutôt d'accord
sur l'immigration il faut se rappeler
quand même de la loi de Gérard Colomb la
loi asile immigration sur laquelle la
majorité déjà s'était largement fracturé
sur sur des sujets voilà
d'humanité c'est c'est quand même aussi
une une part de cette majorité qui vient
de qui vient de la gauche hein bien sûr
sur sur C un malaise évidemment que ça
ravive le le le le clivage droite gauche
et Emmanuel Macron c'est c'est pas son
genre de beauté non plus on voit bien
qu'il est davantage à l'aise sur des
questions du plein emploi c'est à
l'ordre du jour parlementaire cette
semaine sur les questions économiques
mais l'immigration reste un impensé dans
son discours et dans son positionnement
politique d'ailleurs à la base on sait
qu'il a
davantage un un un positionnement
libéral sur le sujet en se disant
pourquoi pourquoi on doit forcément
mettre des gardes fous ça ça c'est de la
main d'œuvre et c'est ça bénéficie à
l'économie c'est quand même initialement
son plutôt son son penchant naturel donc
ça influe évidemment sur sur sa sur ses
troupes mais là on voit bien qu'avec un
un ministre de l'Intérieur qui vient de
la droite et qui a besoin aussi d'avoir
des des
marqueurs sur sur sur ce sujet là aussi
c'est toute la toute la complexité donc
on a du mal à voir comment ça pourrait
aboutir sans qu'il y ait de peau cassé
parce que c'est-à-dire que ce qu'on
donne à la droite on le perd sur la
gauche donc c'est inexplicable fermeté
humanité c'est compatible fermeté
humanité oui c'est évidemment compatible
mais si vous voulez quand vous voulez
faire plaisir à tout le monde vous
faites plaisir à personne et déjà on
sait que si euh
euh et bien le gouvernement euh euh
occulte le ou ou plutôt oublie le
versant humanitaire comme vous le dites
c'est-à-dire embauche des clandestin il
y a toute la gauche du gouvernement qui
qui suivra pas et là il peut très bien
euh voir se constituer un groupe de
fronddeur comme Hollande avait avait eu
en son temps euh lui c'était sur le
travail mais là ça sera sur un autre
sujet et donc il faut qu'il fasse
attention à ça mais je suis assez
d'accord que effectivement le la
proximité des élections européennes
bouleverse un peu probablement les
calculs de d'Emmanuel Macron ouais un
mot sur ce cavalier se de Gérald haranin
ce weekend sur la question de l'Ame hein
c'est une volonté des républicains et
des centristes ici de la transformer en
Amu comment on explique que Gérald
Darmanin contre la vie officielle du
gouvernement et pris position pour
lesalr et comment ça a été perçu
Mathilde alors on imagine d'abord que sa
prise de position qui était dans le
Parisien euh a été euh validée enfin en
tout cas consultée par l'Élysée et
Matignon avant que ce soit publié donc
il y avait quelque part ils étaient au
courant et puis il y a toujours un un un
jeu de positionnement dans une période
de négociation avec des forces
politiques pour essayer de faire aboutir
d'abord ce texte au Sénat dans les
prochaines semaines euh voilà d'essayer
de de raller à lui euh la droite et euh
et potentiellement le le le RN hein
comme il le fait quand même depuis le
début sur sur ce volet là on a bien vu
la réaction quand même un pe oré
d'Élisabeth borne sur ce sujet et là
plus depuis cette opération de tourcoin
on voit bien que l'affrontement l'arvé
entre la première ministre et le
ministre de l'Intérieur commence à être
problématique pour le gouvernement on on
a du mal à voir quelle est la la
cohérence d'ensemble et on voit bien que
le ministre de l'Intérieur est de plus
en plus tenté de s'affranchir aussi de
cette de cette tutelle de matigon pour
avancer lui-même et marquer et marquer
ses ses points avec d'ailleurs une
certaine complicité d'une partie de la
majorité donc ça ça commence à être
assez difficile à vivre pour le pour le
gouvernement et pour Emmanuel Macron
d'avoir au sein même de de son exécutif
un affrontement entre sa première
ministre et son ministre de l'intérieur
c'est une manière pour Géral hermanan de
s'affirmer un peu plus il oui sauf qu'il
faudrait qu'on comprenne ce qu'il veut
euh parce queon réforme laame pour en
faire quoi la M
oui ça parle aux gens ça non ça parle
pas ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
change la vitrine
maison rest le panier de so oui mais
enfin faudrait encore qu'il nous dise
comment et pour est-ce que c'est
vraiment efficace c'est touj c'est
toujours pareil donc j'attends de voir
ce qu'il propose
vraiment dans quels terme c'est c'est
proposé laame on sait même pas combien
d'ailleurs ça coûte à l'état parce qu'on
parle de 1 milliard d'autres parlent de
2 milliards d'EUR
par
an pour ça il faudrait si vous voulez
d'agiter des des concepts comme ça ou
des
idées faut voir ce qui se cache derrière
donc il est urgent d'attendre ouais un
dernier mot Mathilde non mais il y a une
part de posture dans dans dans dans ce
jeul de la part du ministre de
l'Intérieur évidemment donc ensuite lui
il est dans une position de de
négociation et puis encore une fois ce
texte pour l'instant est inscrit à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat à partir du
novembre il n'est pas encore à l'agenda
de l'assemblée et on peine à croire que
la majorité ait envie de s'embourber
dans des débats aussi compliqué à partir
de début 24 alors qu'on aura une
élection européenne quelques mois plus
tard on aura le temps d'en reparler du
coup on va regarder ce qui a la une de
nos quotidiens régionaux avec
[Musique]
Alex et Alex c'est bien sûr l'attaque
d'Israël par le Hamas qui est à la le de
la presse régionale et oui la grande
majorité des J jourau régionaux français
titre ce matin sur ces attaques du Hamas
contre l'État hébreu la guerre et la
sidération à la une de la Charente Libre
à feu et à 100 titre libération
champagne alors que le bilan humain est
extrêmement lourd au terme de ce weekend
au moins 700 morts et 2150 blessés côté
israélien selon les chiffres de l'armée
israélienne 400 morts côté palestinien
plus de 3000 roquettes ont été lancées
depuis Gaza et Israël AR réposté par des
frappes aériennes le mouvement
terroriste du Hamas détient également
une centaines d'otages après ces
attaques et bien on retient la peur de
l'escalade militaire dans la région
c'est à la Une de La du journal Le
dauphine est libéré un conflit qui
inquiète le monde titre la voie du Nord
la crainte de l'embrasement à la Une de
La Provence à cette guerre entre Israël
et le Hamas pourraitembraser le
Moyen-Orient et cela en tout cas va
plomber le processus de normalisation
ces dernières années entre Israël et
certains pays arabes comme l'Arabie
saoudite à la suite de ces attaques le
régime de Riyad a d'ailleurs publié une
réaction proalestinienne donc on avait
perdu l'habitude je la cite le régime de
Riyad évoque une situation explosive
résultant de la poursuite de
l'occupation israélienne la Provence
revient sur la réaction de la communauté
juive de France à ces attaques oui
plusieurs Français revenaient hier
d'Israël où ils ont passé les fêtes du
Nouvel An juif en famille et ces fêtes
se sont transformées en cauchemar
Delphine raconte au journalistes de La
Provence à la sortie de l'aéroport
comment elle a laissé le reste de sa
famille sur place ses cousines ses
tantes avec une immense inquiétude et
puis elle a vu également ces quatre
jeunes hommes de sa famille partir à la
guerre sans hésiter je la cite ils ont
fait leur sac et ils sont partis je n'ai
jamais vécu ça je ne l'oublierai jamais
c'est en tout cas la puissance d'Israël
qui est défiée par cette attaque c'est à
la Une du journal Le télégram des
Israéliens commencent à dénoncer la
défaillance du système de renseignement
de l'État hébreu qui n'a pu empêcher
l'attaque la plus meurtrière de
l'histoire du pays et en même temps
l'heure est à l'unité au sein de la
population et toute la classe politique
également l'opposition appelle à l'un
iion nationale on finit par la Une de
cors matin très nombreuses explosions
qui ont eu lieu cette nuit autour de
Bastia et d'jeaction oui on appelle ça
une nuit bleue c'està-dire une série
d'explosions coordonnées en une seule
nuit une dizaine de bâtiments dans des
résidences secondaires ont été touchés
cette nuit la plupart des cibles étaient
inoccupé pas de blessé mais deux
personnes sous le choc ont été
transférées à l'hôpital cette nuit bleue
laisse penser à une action de la
mouvance clandestine Corse le procureur
de la République d'ajaaccio a saisi le
parquet national antiterroriste merci
beaucoup merci mer Alex pour cette revue
de presse c'est Israël également la Une
du Figaro après l'horreur israël prépare
sa ripost oui c'est on on réserve C cinq
pages sur ce sujet qui est fort
important capital et on va continuer
d'ailleurs probablement encore pendant
de longs jours et à lire évidemment dans
le Figaro un autre conflit c'est
l'Arménie à la une du point à la une du
point cette semaine le conflit arménien
et également de nombreux éclairages de
nombreuses analyses sur ce qui s'est
passé ce weekend à lire sur le point fr
merci beaucoup merci Mathilde on était
ravie de vous retrouver merci d'être
venue à lundi prochain merci Alex merci
à tous de nous avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous à 18h Thomas H sens public
nous on se retrouve demain très bonne
journée